why do so many Valor Pros use this mouse
pad The Artisan xero is considered the
goat when it comes to control pads but
it's pricey sitting at over 60 dollars
U.S and that's before you pay duties on
it luckily last month I was finally able
to get my hands on one to see what all
the hype is about in the past I've had
issues with lighter mice because my
Artisan Tien pad was just too fast but
for this test I used this 55 gram Pulsar
X2 which is in between the weight of
both the super light and the Starlight
Pro and I enjoyed it I only lowered my
sense on valorent by 0.01 because the
increased stopping power of the zero
made it feel pretty damn close to my
setup and it really didn't take long for
me to start finding my groove again so
if you're willing to pay the high price
tag and you're in the market for a
control pad now I think the zero is an
excellent choice